um one more question I think we're gonna
call it a day yes ma'am I'm Molly we're
from CNN I have a question actually
about market share which is sort of what
we're getting at there has been a
suggestion that because of pricing and
design Apple tends to appeal to kind of
a smaller elite rather than that sort of
mass customer base and so I guess once
and for all is it your goal to overtake
the PC in market share I tell you what
our goal is our goal is to make the best
personal computers in the world and to
make products we are proud to sell and
would recommend to our family and
friends and we want to do that at the
lowest price as we can but I have to
tell you there's some stuff in our
industry that we wouldn't be proud to
ship that we wouldn't be proud to
recommend to our family and friends and
we can't do it we just can't ship junk
so there's there's a there are
thresholds that we can't cross because
of who we are
but we want to make the best personal
computers in the industry the industry
that wants that - and what you'll find
is our products are usually not premium
priced you go you go and price out our
competitors products and you add the
features that you have to add to make
them useful and you'll find in some
cases they are more expensive than our
products the difference is we don't
offer stripped-down lousy products you
know we just don't offer categories of
products like that but if you move those
aside and compare us with our
competitors I think we compare pretty
favorably and a lot of people have been
doing that and saying that now for the
last 18 months